are you looking to build and showcase  your cloud skills  want an easy way to show them off you  can now earn skill badges from google  cloud  to demonstrate your growing cloud  competencies  here's how it works first you need to  join the google cloud skills challenge  this gives you 30 days of free access to  google cloud labs  then choose the track you're interested  in and get started  each track has a number of skill badges  up for grabs  to earn a badge you'll need to complete  a series of google cloud labs  then you'll need to pass a final  challenge lab designed to test your  skills  once you've earned a badge showcase what  you've learned  you could add it to your resume and  share it with your network  ready to go join the google cloud skills  challenge today  and start earning your skill badges